hey guys my name is Caitlin and I'm
trying the 100 ab challenge so by day
I'm usually working behind the scenes
here at BuzzFeed as a production
coordinator but in my free time I'm
known as the clean fit on Instagram and
hopefully YouTube
I'm low-key a fitness youtuber junkie so
I actually came upon this one youtuber
named Blogilates her actual name is
Casey ho so she does a million 30-day
challenges like she does an ABS one she
does a glutes one she just legs when
aren't like she has so many and I happen
to choose ABS because that is actually
my favorite part of the body to work I'm
doing this challenge because my word of
the year for 2020 is consistency I feel
like that's one thing that I'm not
really good at doing I'm not consistent
and a lot of things that I do especially
my workouts I actually have tried a
couple challenges and it's not that it
didn't work okay it was that I didn't
work I was not consistent my lifestyle
requires me to have a pretty healthy
diet already so I won't be changing my
diet per se but I do know for sure that
I am taking dairy out because I'm not
gonna lie to you I think I'm lactose
intolerant I haven't gone to the doctor
for it yet who knows but I do get the
bubble guts and I get bloated that is a
thing it's nasty so I really want to
work on making sure that my abs become
toned and doing this challenge and I
just feel like if I'm gonna do 100 abs
for 30 days then I'm starting my year
off right
they say summer bodies are made in the
winter so that's what we gonna do you
know day one we started out pretty
smooth like we started with the hundreds
and honestly it was a lot more arm work
than anything so I didn't really feel it
like I I genuinely was like oh this
gonna be a breeze like okay whatever
cool then we got to day two I think it
was the cross crunch kick and after 50 I
felt it I was like oh okay Blogilates
you're really trying it I think you want
to fight oh it didn't take me long to
realize that I would have to do these
workouts in sets I
not doing 100 full-out like it was just
not happening so I did like sets of 4
sets of 2 they never said that she
couldn't do sets so I still did it
alright so by day 10 they started
hitting some of my favorite workouts
which was perfect for me it was like
planks and hip twists and I'm used to
that I've been doing that through my ab
routine through my fitness journey for a
minute so like around that time they
tend to 15 I was chilling a little bit
but then day 15 hit and like I've never
heard of some of these workouts in my
life like some of them were having me
defy gravity like what the hell is star
abs I took so many pauses within my
workouts like I didn't even do sets I
did like one pause what let me remind
you that this is during holiday season
right so I have Christmas I have moving
because I was also moving at this time
and then I got these workouts these ab
challenges were not letting up they were
actually getting harder
[Music]
luckily for me because it was the
holiday season I was around family I was
a room friends what is all this hair
what is this and just people who were
actually like I would enjoy which was
super exciting for me yes you are
well if you lean back even keel away
are you even going in a circle I don't I
had my auntie's join I had my brother it
was great so that was amazing and by day
30 I felt I was just so happy
[Applause]
[Music]
you know like this is good for me before
versus now like
obviously there's always room for
improvement but this for me this is a
good result for a month worth of apps so
I would say that this challenge was hard
but it wasn't impossible it actually
pushed me to see what my limits were and
what it is that I could do and what I
couldn't do and in that sense now I know
better and and now I'm better for it in
terms of like my fitness journey as a
person like I'm just I'm so happy that I
actually did this and I actually kind of
want to do another challenge now I
definitely would recommend this
challenge I give it a ten out of ten for
sure for me it definitely set the tone
for the rest of my year which is super
dope and I hope that I'm consistent in
everything that I do for the rest of 23
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]